okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
incremental language development of
Wolff language heading for our next
release version 12.1 first topic of the
day documentation for data set yes so we
have a lot of work to do here to include
all the new options that this is a demon
and we also want to change the structure
of this the mutation page so we wanted
to discuss with you general ideas about
how to do it okay so what I would do is
use iodized because rather than having a
big example with a single main important
in many operations we would prefer to
have several examples each one with its
input so why don't we have a data set
and an icon icon eyes thing where they
icon eyes is says something like planet
data set that's what I'm saying so if we
say something like this
okay so if what we do I know this will
work is to say dataset of planets
example and use that as the thing that
we I know what that is but anyway who
knows what that is I mean that's that's
that's I'm running some weird version
here and it's got a fine but I think
that would be a reasonable thing to use
do you agree the repetition of example
day right now let's take a look at the
data set page yes I mean clearly dataset
is going to need additional
documentation so it has a very large
notes section which is separated into
subsections the information is important
of course this wasn't bad it mean it's
it's a bit non-standard we have other
pages in which we section that's
ridiculous you can't call it that
we should call that simplified syntax
special syntax syntactic shortcuts
better look I mean this is way you know
unfortunates are very complicated
unfortunately I don't know I mean this
is clearly useful information this is
the wrong presentation of it this should
be in a tutorial is there not a tutorial
but the fundamental parts of of it
should remain here yes
look I don't think it's bad look it's
probably not bad to have this here add
yet another subsection they are
dedicated to the options to the very
substance that this is having right that
plus there by the way Jose if people
complain they can't hear you
I can hear you just fine for some reason
I can hear you fine it's it's not
transmitting um well if it's still a
problem will will that's odd because I
can hear it can other Chris can you hear
I'm fine so I think this is an issue but
the way this is bridging to the live
stream so somebody can touch look at
that oh okay um alright anyway
somebody's asking about shortcut for I
can eyes yeah we probably should have
one of those I mean I think that
in the right-click menu icon eyes is
becoming enough of a thing that it's
probably worthwhile for us to have this
yes and that's for a different meeting
and that's Devon maybe you can take that
too that'll be a John folks path story
yeah okay I agree that it's time I think
it's useful enough it's time to do that
um looks like we have a keyboard
shortcut what is it
ctrl command ' absolutely so why doesn't
that show up in the right-click menu
that's weird why does the right-click
menu not have keyboard shortcut
information in it seems wrong to me okay
that's the issue for path and so on okay
okay
cuz I don't know where it is in here
well there it is okay I wonder what
anybody uses comment on comments
selection I use it daily yeah all the
time
okay I just had to learn it right it's
probably been there for 20 years I've
never used it okay alright okay let's
not let's not discuss removing it then
uh I should just use it um okay what's
the other question about data set um I
mean other than that we've got to have
yet more sections about some options and
so on display options basically yes so
perhaps you can have a look at their
grid page because probably we should
imitate that structure how they
explained all the options there will
need to be an option section and
something in the notes section that
explains the general syntax for options
like this one well what I mean this is
all in the notes section
yeah but then but then on the options
section the individual options are
described but the general syntax is
described in the notes right there
should be an initial part explaining the
options in general with the table Makia
and then yes although it would be nice
to move some of that documentation to
the documentation of the options
themselves unless that's incompatible
with what um with the way that you know
unless it's I mean we should check the
documentation of those options doesn't
conflict with what happens for you know
for datastore for grid and other things
making sense and if it does you know we
may have to break down and start having
some subsections and some of these
options um I mean the truth is look the
thing we've got to do with data set is
you know create a tech note that
explains more all the stuff yes it is a
ridiculous you know Swiss Army knife of
a function to its benefit all right
anything else about about data set here
how is all your work on data set options
and so on coming along
well it's merged I have work to do this
week to get a
in shape before the freeze but yeah I'm
on track I think to get it now did you
you didn't manage to make any resize
ability types down no no no no no is it
merged into the head branch build yeah
which hasn't been built yet Oh what is
it in the prototype build yeah it's on
the prototype build this prototype
builders that too old no it's better the
prototype build for a long time by the
way have we looked at some additional
examples I really think the examples
that we have and we should get some
other examples that come from you know
the data repository and so on for this
including some deeper ones for instance
don't you think yeah it would be nice to
have some more okay so why don't you
look why don't you ask the folks who've
been working on the data repository if
they can suggest some and maybe you can
take some things that are in the data
repository and slim them down so they're
not quite as as you know many items
because they don't think that's the main
point that we're trying to illustrate
here right okay so is this your new
formatting yeah so if I then click what
can I do I click on this what am i doing
it should drill down if you click there
didn't it yeah that drills gone but it's
always done that yeah you told so if you
right click you get the menu I did that
but I didn't get any interesting menu
are you you you have to be on the I
think you have to have the hand cursor
there okay
so then like I can say sort here I took
its time there is a front end issue a
lot of box constructs are way too slow
okay
I understand that that's I know that the
most recent builds I haven't been using
the most recent build for that reason
okay okay well let's let's I mean what
happens if I just want to show five
elements here a max items data said
right max item zero five I assume you'll
fix that syntax coloring right yeah okay
by the way I assume you'll have examples
even in the basic example set of showing
how to reformat a data set like this so
what do you mean by reformat well I mean
show it with different format like oh I
see wrapping everything aside and giving
options yes yes I mean I presumably this
thing itself is a singly wrapped data
set right once I have this yeah nothing
lis wrapped yes and okay good all right
let's move on to the next item
it can yes that would be another good
thing to start using yes we've got a
number of nice data sets there although
those tend to be not no deeper than you
know they don't trying to be terribly
deep be nice to show some that are
pretty deep I'm sure we can do some
there that are you know country
administrative division sort of you know
country state county city type things
that'll get somewhat deep maybe you
could do something I don't know some
some type of thing in the world that
there aren't that many of telescopes or
something and you could do that type of
you know country country city
whatever it is thing for those big
telescopes particle accelerators they're
even fewer particle accelerators um okay
should we go on here and there's that
for Chris I made one trivial change I'll
push it back in
to the ends of the repo okay thanks okay
thanks a lot okay
time remaining so these this is a new
function and I would like to discuss the
documentation okay so time remaining is
within a time constraint how much time
is remaining it's so for example if I
just run time remaining just in general
oops you need space okay all right
is it gonna give infinity yes in it only
for meetings okay about that okay
all right let's look at the page
to the earliest constraint
I wouldn't say abort well it isn't abort
isn't it interruption the earliest time
constraint that really is the only type
of constraint this reacts to correct yes
what else could okay um um presumably is
this an absolute time it's the number of
seconds that's an absolute time it's not
CPU time you time the other functions
like time constraint they all say it is
C buta I don't know that I believe that
so I I mean suppose you have multiple
threads running or something yell so
you're doubling your CPU usage but I
don't I think it reacts to seconds in
absolute time because I think that's out
that pole and you run it and and look at
a pause for example examples I think
they all use many of them if you use
pause it'll react to the amount of time
in the pause pretty much to do that but
that's not really a time constraint um
okay by the way another point made by
Brian on the live stream is why not make
why did the thing have a non rear why
did the data set have a non reactive
header except for the label if you could
pass that on to Chris I don't know the
answer to that it doesn't seem to make
sense to me
what the heck is that
oh I see time constraint pause of one
and that in time remaining exactly
so time remaining is evaluated after the
pause okay but now is it CPU time well
that's the way walk lock the
documentation page of time constraint
says it's looking at CPU time okay all
right
question on our live stream which I was
also going to ask is why is this
returning a number not a quantity that's
to follow all the functions like session
time yeah I think we should probably
have this be just a number I think it's
gonna end up being computational and
seconds are the obvious number it's kind
of a shame that it can't be a quantity
but I just don't think it's all that
useful to be it be a quantity now I mean
one could ask about time remaining in
the case of some kind of push ideal task
or some other thing I mean oh do we
think time remaining is only going to be
relevant to time constraints I think
look I think for now doing it with
respect to the nearest neighboring time
constraint is a reasonable thing to do
in some time in the future we could
imagine something where there's a
progress monitoring where you could call
time remaining from inside a progress
monitor inside some function and it
would say something useful right
it doesn't have any arguments perhaps in
the future it would take as an argument
this thing it should look at yeah right
well I mean then this question I was
mentioned also on the live stream about
about a bunch of nested time constraints
and camryn walk
stack basically and look at the times
available on all those time constraints
I don't know whether we have that data
readily available well what happens
right now with nested time constraints
is that time remaining we look at the
earliest one I think might not be the
one nested in other words if I had the
time constraint them my nearest
neighboring time constraint could be a
30 second time constraint but there
could be something over outside of that
that's a five second time constraint
probably the first time at a hit and
that's why it says earliest several
times right okay so the question
otherwise time constraint not earlier in
the seal so here it seems highly
relevant to this mmm yes I mean doesn't
that time constraint doesn't have
function with that time constraint
doesn't that hit the same isn't that
effectively defining a time constraint
right well we should check the list but
I think it is yeah now an abort
obviously you don't know it's gonna
happen so okay does it mention something
interesting here is the behavior with
respect to abort protect so if there is
an abort protect inside time constraint
then time remaining we'll be looking at
the time constraint even though the
operation is not going to stop okay well
right way
you know we should say until the
earliest enclosing will request the
current computation to stop because it
may not in fact stop on cue if you
understand what I'm saying we could if
we wanted to have a what amounts to an
MI inside abort protect that also
queries the act of you know state of
these things but that's another function
for another day it would go through the
same C code basically as time remaining
well and we need to also look at as we
do some I mean the look cloud object
block is another thing the locking code
there I mean there are a lot of these
things that we need to know are we
inside a some kind of critical region
type thing it's similar to the the way
that we do what is it called the thing
that wraps the interface switch thing
that determines how you draw a 3d
graphic based on whether you're rotating
the mouse or not know what I'm talking
about performance goal for ya and that
then query basically
hmm I thought there doesn't mention it
here um let me just look at two plot 3d
because that should have a default that
is oh great
think this thing you're thinking of is
documented in the one of the the
manipulate controls because it shows up
there too oh yeah
control active sounds right
right we should mention that in the page
was I just looking at I was just looking
at
performance goal right yes I've done our
pajamas
I think it should get mentioned there
and one earth is dollar performance goal
not mentioned here
okay that does mention it it's very odd
but for some strange reason this doesn't
mention performance coal you know I
think back in the day we didn't make
some of these very obvious see also is
what we really should um
okay alright that's that okay so does it
need to say something about I bought
protect here it needs to say something
about whether its CPU time I'm pretty
sure it's wall clock well then it isn't
consistent with time constraint is it it
is because I'm pretty sure time
constraint is also wall clock so I don't
have a look at the last note of time
constraint perhaps I'm misinterpreting
it we may not have the right people here
to talk about this we may not have the
right people unless we want to see
whether John is available Devin could
you see if John is available yeah what
John faults
well I oh you think he's not the
relevant person no I don't think so is
this is Colonel stuff okay who is the
relevant person possibly Tom possibly
myself I'm not sure who else has looked
at it I think most other people are long
gone
okay hold on
you
ah point made by Ethan on livestream of
time remaining uses the task system take
care about clouds and sub kernels yeah I
think this is very much using
we need to clarify whether this is CP
your time I I mean I think it's CPU time
because I think it's
I think it's simply asking
given the elapsed time well I don't know
I don't know we need to find this out um
by the way this should this should this
should reference system process data
should it not because that is going to
tell you things about how much time a
process is spent
see system time and so on and this
should probably refer back to time
remaining and I wonder whether this
should refer to abort
perhaps not let's see that seems
relevant if your inner process kill
process kills a process there um miss
Ternan training is a little weird but I
think it's a useful vector to send
people um let's see
Ethan is commenting on how time slows
down with the front end is that a large
memory pressures yeah I mean we need to
know how its implemented I don't know um
so you've got questions here about
knitting yes
boy I have to roll out the elephant
again um okay so let's see time
constrained
great it's an obsolete page repeated
timing session time
think it probably goes here um probably
lit there of thank estranged time for me
no I I'm concerned I think I can answer
your question about CPU vs. wall clock
its wall clock okay um I'm thinking
where to put it on this page because
these are really time I think it goes at
the top of his time constraint I don't
think so cuz this is mostly about how to
measure how long something is taking
it's not down in the details of what you
of the code you write
um I'm not even sure it belongs on this
page there was another one on debugging
yes
month back is that that's a different
thing
that's memory
I'm thinking here you know what I'm
gonna put it down here I'm gonna put it
here um
let's see
what should we say time remaining until
a time constraint yes or in a time
constrained time remaining in a running
program until the time constraint it's a
little obscure but I think ok um
you
ethan is commenting that on the time
goal page since different computer
systems run different speeds the same
setting for time goal can lead to
different results on different systems
yes
that does come up every so often
you know I don't really know why time
goal isn't listed here seems like an
obvious thing to list
you
you
I don't want to say
time
you
you
you know time before a time constraint
I pick one just has to give an
indication of what's going on it's
better to have a few words and let
people click okay but we did not put in
time goal which is crazy here
we clearly should have time goal in this
list even though would be good to have
it in other functions but it's hard to
know I mean most functions you know
machine learning functions have the
feature that you just sort of do more of
them and they get better hopefully few
other functions have that feature
although I can imagine certain iterative
numerical functions could do that which
of those functions have a time
constraint
and which functions could have a time
goal instead of a time constraint this
is the wrong group to discuss that I
wonder whether we should put time
remaining in this list here
probably not I do think though that the
natural place is the guide page for
union and debugging
you
you
we're in the time apart that is a time
subsection further up
okay
you
you
you
you
how do we want to say this to tell in
the amount of time remaining in a
running program destination that the
fact that it is constrained time
remaining you know constrain a turn or
would you run before time before a time
constant should time remaining work on
an audio/video file what's playing yes
but where would you call it what would
you call that in
I don't know whether it fits here you
know this page is about I mean how would
you use this well it's a matter of
deciding in real time whether to do
something because if you know how long
it's going to take and there is nothing
last time you do it right right but this
is a different page this is about well
okay all right all right all right
they're fair enough that's a reasonable
thing to say um I guess that's a
reasonable thing to say okay could time
remaining work in an audio/video file
what would call it so
playing an audiophile what what is
actually what code is running when you
do that
okay by the way we're going to need a
comment about CPU time here
I don't know what it should say though
but so we right wait a minute you're
saying um
time remaining you said Danny you said
time remaining time remaining is based
on absolute are we calling it wall clock
time absolute is probably a synonymous
effectively and it goes with timing
function right it's based on absolute
real time not just CPU time no but that
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any sense
look the time constraint is in CPU time
this is say is not just because it is
well it says wrong do time constraint of
pause of to print X 3 well CPU time but
Poor's isn't isn't as a weird use of CPU
time isn't it it doesn't show up on CPU
time it doesn't react to timing okay who
definitively knows how this works well I
sort of do that's not off the top of my
head but so what are you trying to tell
me here okay this this will print if you
change the time constraint to 1 it will
not however if you wrapped timing around
that pause you would get something like
0 points you know 0 something
so the pause is not taking CPU time as
measured by timing okay I love the
comment that absolute time would have n
Stein rolling around his grave where
else just wait for my project in a few
weeks um we will have more to say about
absolute time okay Safari the thing to
do here SEP this understanding that
final note in time constraint which is
there's to be n correct but I think this
is not for this meeting I think we gotta
go off and research that because this
doesn't make sense if this is both um
you know it can't be time constraint
can't be asking for CPU time and then
this time remaining is measured in
absolute time that would make no sense
time constraint is not asking for CPU
time it is based on absolute yeah I
think that is right it doesn't notice is
stretch I'm wrong to investigate yeah
right the term wrong does come to mind
okay but but so what does it do with
with other processes what does it do
with surprise so it's absolute time in
the sense of wall clock time which means
it doesn't care we need to understand
this this is given by this is as given
by absolute timing not as given by
timing basically yes so we need to we
need to unscramble that all right let's
continue I think you raised an issue of
sub processes and dialogues and the like
and
I think is a thorny mess we don't I
don't think we have a full handle on
that so what is your point there just
something to add to this discussion that
you seem to want to have down the road
about what all these things do well
you're saying does a time constraint
okay so you're saying let's try this
okay so I'm gonna do an input in the
middle of this so I'm gonna say time
constraint I predict this is not going
to do what you think pause one print one
you're wrong by definition because I'm
not sure what it'll do
okay all right input print input
okay so let's go ahead and say time
constrain this for you means st. right
seconds okay I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting I'm waiting
that was very impolite of it they didn't
wait for me okay that's good actually
that supports your theory and by the way
that example should probably be in the
in documentation for time-constrained
I mean it just said forget it now if
this was a modal dialogue which I
thought it was what is it gonna do when
I press okay just goes off into lala
land Wow well I'm impressed that it
didn't do anything much crazier it was
actually snickering nananana booboo but
you didn't hear it I'm a little worried
that that might cause a very nasty bug
but there's something modal happening
like that
I mean input is a modal dialogue right a
minute it waits normal input will wait
for me to type something in before I oh
my guess is that one would want to
protect those with abort protect and
what is the behavior here if I say abort
protect well
hope it works thousand one two thousand
two one thousand three one thousand four
one thousand five I think it's gonna
work but what it returned was aborted
that's really weird
the time constrained he does eventually
abort it does I don't think it gets
wiped away it gets pro delayed by the
abort 4 - I search a saying I see what
you're saying so if actively that we
need to make notes about this and the
time constraint documentation that this
can warp time effectively by having this
critical section but it keeps running
even though it knows it's got to stop
right which is the behavior we want from
abort project no I know it's right that
I'm quite sure okay but what's the
relationship between time remaining and
a boat protect well there's an example
in the page so what happens is that time
remaining is still reporting the
constraint just that the constraint does
happen so we need to say that in the
documentation up here we are saying
before we could have a separate function
that actually pulls to see whether
aborts are disabled you're effectively
am I in an abort protected or other
critical section no I agree I look I
think the right way to do that is some
general function that asks the status I
mean it you know look what we have right
now is dollar evaluation environment
right which is answering questions like
that
what answers the question am I in a
top-level session
if I go inside a dialogue if I say input
of dollar valuation of Arnold what does
it do I don't know
obsession okay so that's the granularity
that it knows about of that but I think
related to a valuation environment there
are other things that
you
Wow okay yeah so this is a question that
I mean there should be a dollar variable
that says are you inside an abort
protect or a function that says are you
inside an abort protect I agree
similar to evaluation environment but
there may be other conditions that you
might be inside of like are you inside
are you waiting for the user are you
inside a modal thing waiting for the
user I'm making sense in other words
what is on the stack above you that
effects execution and returning values
are you insert a dynamic I I don't know
how one would answer all of that the
abort protect one is is a matter I
understand that specific one but I'm
saying let's roll those all together
let's talk about them let's let's
inventory what those things are the
evaluation state basically
yeah you don't like an evaluation state
I think you will need both John and Tom
for that meeting fine let's let's make
sure we do that okay but here let's just
add appropriate notes to time remaining
and then we can wrap that one up
make sense okay and then yeah I've
written pitches for these three okay
let's start with reverse supplied do you
have you knitted these among them but
not with other functions need some notes
but I wasn't sure how to explain it well
to just say it's equivalent to now I
like what you've done so this is
necessarily a form of F because it isn't
a form of effort or is it should we call
it the form of F I think this was trying
to imitate what we originally wrote for
courage I see all right let's look at
the other ones here
so this structure of represents
something so that okay
what is this one now is a current - yes
that's right that's the reordering
that's the well be true permutation
basically exactly or extraction of
sacrifice I've said right it could also
I wish take a argument as your total
former
what the heck is that K greater than
equal to max of those yes that one with
the rule says it's waiting to get K
arguments and then it will extract those
in the list in the previous case it will
no I understand K argument where it it
extracts the K arguments it takes the K
arguments and then extracts those in the
list which may be fewer right right
right right right right okay hold on
I think that this can be said better so
such that operator applied okay um so
this
um that requires at least what does it
do it requires at least K arguments
right yes and it will take the first K
and ignore the rest ignore or leave them
hanging out there okay look why don't we
try saying represents an operator form
of F that takes
takes K arguments and X and assess those
in the list alright that takes
what happens okay so the an argument
case it doesn't chop off what does it do
here so it takes if we say operator
applied um it's right sorry I think you
have fun operator operator this was
renamed gesture okay
okay doesn't exist in that bill but it
does in this one um okay so operator F
and then let's say I say three four here
okay then I say ABCDE because the
largest integer is 4 it will decide that
it it waits for 4 elements elements you
cannot do anything earlier now exactly
now now that complains that it cannot
extract 3 & 4 from 2 but it is writes 5
goes to 3 4 then we wait for the file
and extract reform
okay okay so then what what you're
really saying is um let's see since this
is basically like the previous usage
methods can we just have something like
specifies that you're using K arguments
and not repeat all of the same no no
absolutely that's what I'm trying to do
yeah but
let's see assumes a K argument function
I think here the confusion is the number
of arguments of s versus the number of
arguments of the operator form of F yes
represents an operator form that takes K
arguments I mean really that's what we
have to say okay keep inequality or no
no we'll put that in the notes
let's see we're looking at question from
sander here who's asking would why was
this working what if I was working all
over here yes so these functions are
recognized ik about the structure of
brackets right you can even insert empty
brackets and there will be if not I
think we should put that as the first
note honestly what do you think I think
that's useful to say that as the first
note here
and by the way in terms of keywords do
we have okay good
um all right
what else's role
to this
what happens if you I predict that's
gonna turn into a thing with a four
there yep there it is I hope we've got
examples that show all these things
happening was effectively their own page
of Curie just right right
okay let's look let's look at the career
plight page so this is not for some
reason working there hold on
okay so yes so in this page we have to
change the second one by the one
so this thing here curry applied there
yeah exactly because now we have an
operator front for curry applied rather
than a default second argument for curry
of life which is what operator bite us I
know so we should put that right here at
the top so that that's my okay
so why don't we just go ahead and do
that
wait a minute so this is that can be
applied to a function of n arguments
right it represents an operator form of
curry applied as you said there
that can be applied to a function to
produce an operator form apply to a
function to produce to represent an
operator form with n arguments okay then
that goes away
yes and we should change their decay in
case we need to say itself represents an
operator form this is obscure most
people when they read this will not
understand it
what's the K case you're just saying we
should change it as we did before
exactly mr. functions are very similar
I asked Raman about these names he was
okay with him he immediately thought of
another case of this applied family
which he says he uses a lot which is
threw up light which happens to be our
head map that was interesting but is not
trust and what does it do it it's a it's
a function that takes in the first pair
of brackets our list of functions and
then it applies all of them all of them
to an X so it will be through applied
bracket list of functions F G H okay in
a list list F G H now close bracket open
bracket X and this returns list f of X G
of X it's like through of the list
rocket attacks I see so they all go
through if we did have G H of X there is
an interesting construct it's exactly
our head map which is the earliest open
still open I indicated just we never
eaten a name well that's interesting
through applied is not super clear
either because through itself is not
super clear but it's interesting
connection
yeah well I like that actually I think
that's I mean okay yeah we need more
examples here
do we have examples um okay this looks
good I wonder whether we have examples
from from very from things like queries
and data set and so on yes I think I
think I very recently added support for
curry in datacite so yeah I should add
example yeah so how it's used
okay all right let's look at missing
here for a minute okay um let's see what
can we knit to well okay let's first of
all look at these things like construct
I think Oh you've put curry in there so
we should look for where curry got
mentioned exactly yeah I will make sure
I eat I messed this up um okay but but
do we want to reference operator applied
or I think so or courier do we want to
reference operator applied here or do we
want to reference curry okay okay well
let's just look at where we mentioned
curry do we we already net curry at all
yes in both pages it's in function
composition operator forms of course and
the function
Xander is pointing out that through
applied identity comma F would be a
useful way to pair an argument with its
function value yes I agree
so the idea was paired is to take what
is the idea I am forgetting there's SF
and then another bracket X actually this
could be called pair up light
well and that is going to return X f of
X
I mean it is interesting to see how
through applied I think through apply is
a better than head map I mean they're
both kind of obscure but but um I like
the idea of aligning it with yeah I
agree and having the applied family that
is a head related headdress
type thing
the suggestions for examples compared
with other languages code for higher
order operators korean swift looks like
something here
um so Santa and Ethan are both saying
that through apply it would be something
they would use all the time honestly so
would I it's a good argument for having
it I think it's indeed ticketing or
something like that but it's just we
never agreed on a name yes well maybe
we've got it here is there another
possible name for this Sandra is keen on
paired
you know I would have thought okay what
would this be if it if reverse applied
means F X Y is applied to Y X does list
applied
what does list applied mean doesn't mean
this thing does it mean something
different it means something about
threading yeah I think we have a
homogeneous concept of applied here it's
more of a general idea of do something
with this function to do something
non-standard right apply this function
an unusual way
I mean the truth is list applied there
is a meaning to that that would be this
this this would be F of list XYZ that
would be the analog of Reverse applied I
think it's not precise analog but it's a
similar thing and I mean that is you
know the alternative is F of which is
perfectly you know it's not horrifying
or F composed with lists that would work
wouldn't it
well that's a little complicated because
now we got to go like this right is that
gonna work
yes that's kind of nice
um all right let's look at our
functional programming page
well we've definitely got to have the
applied family on here functions with
operator forms okay so this is the page
for curry boy okay so we have to have
something on here it's going to be
difficult to distinguish yeah hold on
hold on hold on
to be applied in operator form as an
operator form um now we could say here
Curie applied
okay let me let's let's maybe so we've
got also reverse applied here
let's see
perhaps you can put together operator
applied and courier plight because they
do fundamentally the same thing
[Music]
ethan is mentioning a general applied
decorator i would love to have something
like that but i don't understand what it
does
okay wait a minute
we could say something like I mean I was
thinking of doing the curry of ending
something like that perhaps good to me
turn a function into one to be applied
as into one to be applied
you
not super happy with this but okay
you
obviously here
I think we should put it at the end of
these
okay let's go to apply from
here if I'm not mistaken let's see what
do we want to do we want to
grunts operator applied from here 5f
not sure oona China maybe confusing
perhaps construct the function that
shipped well probably composition we
want to mention operator applied okay we
already mentioned it there let's mention
at the end of this the other place we
definitely want to mention the Curie
thing is in function R we do
Hurd reminds of Jay a hook in the J
language of Kurds interesting I haven't
really followed the Post APL APL um my
god well a hawk of fork what is this I
don't even understand what the those are
identical oh YX oh my well I think that
the main main thing there's the whole
family of things that manipulate heads
of expressions is some is an interesting
you know general area okay
let's see where else do we have to
reference operator forms just right
composition mention does does right
composition of left composition do they
care about Reverse applied I think so
I do have examples of how to convert
some of these into the other one using
traverse of light which composition on
right composition for example
um okay I'm for some reason I'm a little
spaced out here so I'm not thinking as
clearly as I should we probably should
do one more iteration on looking at can
you try and surface more places where
these could be referenced and then we'll
check on that um I think we still need
to discuss I mean we're not gonna get it
for 12.1 but paired and through applied
are both interesting Sanders commenting
that paired could have multiple
arguments and it could go X f of X G of
X yeah I mean I like paired cuz I do use
it all the time
um right I mean unfortunately okay it's
not so bit related to this a touch
coordinates functions that we discussed
what is that doin yes
so this idea of having values attached
in lists with their coordinates so so if
we had a multi and multi-dimensional
case we would have to say something like
X comma Y comma C comma f of X Y see
what are you saying you're saying what
do you think yes if we have the function
f of X Y C how do we combine it with the
coordinates so we were cutting a
function called touch coordinates or
coordinate x or something like that in
which we we can put them all in a list
like X comma Y comma C comma F or M or
the first three in the list or in an
association things about what was the
point of us yes the point of this was
getting an array
of values and then saying oh this
correspond to the ranges from 2 X 1 1
and then we create all this well so
you're saying this is paired about 4 XYZ
yes but we have this more flexible way
because sometimes you will want the
flattened version of that or or or rules
etc well so so I mean then the obvious
question is what happens what does
paired of F X Y Z do right
but these are the function is a lot more
powerful third seems like a simpler so I
mean you know obviously this could in
principle be X Y Z f of X Y Z right and
then the question would be so pad of F
and G of X Y could be XY f of X Y G of X
Y it's not completely crazy I think
alright let's store this away in our
functional programming list um this
should be called paired Oh one need to
talk about paired some more I mean I I
do really think that this whole question
about how to manipulate heads of
expressions when they get more
complicated which we haven't you know
cuz because for example let's imagine
that we have a whole nest of operator
applied and pads and things like that we
don't have a lot of functions that
operate on a head and when we have the
old function operate that has not been
much used which does operate on heads
right what would be a button for that
situation
the situation in which we have many
brackets right I understand so so I mean
what we need is a is the thing that the
analog of double blank that represents
multi bracketing we're gonna need that I
mean that's a you know what is that I
mean is that could we have okay this
gets a little weird but could we have an
operator applied form in which like for
example what if we had blanks there is
that really weird well the premise that
we always need to know how many
arguments we are waiting for it was
unspecified that that in this function
can it work
what about as K form
it could be reverse so K is a number but
then when we put on the right-hand side
of the rule is above that could do
something perhaps okay so let's say this
is four and then it's arrow and blank so
then that will look for I mean the truth
is okay
truth is we need the following function
truth is we need a function that tells
us what the structure so here's what we
need
um
just say something like operator
structure
okay
okay let's imagine it's
Reiter to list f comma 4
goes to F of list X Y Z W
you
you
- I'm saying and perhaps the X and wise
also enlists yes for consistency that's
necessary right so in other words this
is taking an arbitrary structure and so
that I mean in other words what this is
doing is it's taking a left tree I don't
even think that in this case right if we
were to do a tree form of this do we
even handle left trees no we don't and
that's another separate thing as to is
to have tree form handle left trees I
mean you know in other words what we
should do is have a heads argument which
I bet we don't have a heads are true in
tree form which means go and do
something I don't know exactly what it
is for to represent the tree of the head
I think would be to have one of these
trees inside yellow oh yeah it's ready
right but so so this type of thing the
question is could we I mean the real
thing we want to do is we want to say
pattern match on F of you know sort of
I'm gonna say any structure but that's a
bad name you know this and that wants to
match I mean that would have to match in
an operator to list kind of way I claim
so the match would be bla bla bla then F
of
say Q there would bind you know would
bind Q to this kind of list here there
we go the fighting chance of doing
something with it but this isn't correct
look at the structure it's not correct
see because because by the time you've
said that you've already you know you've
already cooked the goose because that's
already this thing here it's it's again
this argument for what it is is really
it's an argument structure of F comma Q
blank which is equivalent to anything
like this it's very much like an
operator applied
I claim that this thing here has to
match see this is so weird because this
is the pattern matcher uses in many
cases the head of the head of the head
to do things anyway I have to run um
more functional programming fun another
time
I mean this is something we do have to
solve I know we've talked about this
before we should put this on an aisle
the agenda to discuss this particular
thing it's gonna be heavy lifting
because it involves you know thinking
about I mean the concept of a head yeah
it's a complicated thing yeah all right
I'll push back all these documentation
pages and try and surface some other
other cases of this and we will continue
okay talk to you soon thanks to folks on
the livestream